you have a comet that's coming in it was
unknown before so last year it was
discovered when you look at its orbit we
find out that it's 50 000 Years Around
The Sun wow Sun's gravity goes well
beyond Neptune the last planet from the
Sun
get over it yeah
damn he did it again so it goes well
beyond Neptune it goes into the Kuiper
belt of comets right where Pluto is a
member and then beyond that there is a
spherical repository of Frozen objects
comets that goes practically halfway out
to the nearest star this was predicted
to be there by a Dutch astronomer named
Jan ort it's called the ort Cloud oh
this comet comes to us from the Oort
cloud and any comment that comes to us
from the work cloud has never been seen
in Civilization that's how long those
trajectories take wow